before we go here is one thing you can
do today
to live a happy healthy and more
productive life it is part of our
partnership with gretchen rubin and her
award-winning podcast
happier gretchen a new york times
best-selling author joins us now with
how we can all make a contribution
during this pandemic
and social unrest the season of it we
should say good morning gretchen
and you say one way people can give back
is to schedule
an empower explain that to us
well now more than ever as you say we're
wanting to put our values into the world
and research shows that if we decide
exactly when and how we're going to do
that we're much more likely to follow
through with that intention
so if we schedule an empower hour for at
least an hour to work on
racial justice or environmentalism or
hunger up we're much more likely to
follow through
and take actions that put our values
into the world you say one example of
how people can use
empower or the empower hour is to
register to vote
how else can people get more involved to
help create change in their community
so absolutely people are wanting to help
others to register to vote
um they're also wanting to help with
food banks they're wanting to do
all sorts of things social issues book
club that's a great way to have a
difficult searching conversation to
educate ourselves
um and to make sure that we read all
those books that are on our bookstand
that we know that we really want to read
yeah how does all of that help to impact
somebody else's happiness
well it's absolutely true that the
antidote to anxiety is action so when we
do good in the world we make ourselves
feel better and also
we're seeing that we're bringing about
change we're using this time of
adversity
to make ourselves stronger to bring our
communities together people who do good
deeds
feel more gratitude they feel less
stressed they feel happier
do good feel good it really works yeah
it sounds like a lot of things we should
already be doing gretchen it's going to
make a better community
thank you so much for talking to us